as a group the nominees for Best Actress
tonight have been nominated 24 times and
have won four Oscars now it's time to
make that five Oscars the nominees for
performance by an actress in a leading
role for her portrayal of a Mother
Superior trying desperately to maintain
decorum in a troubled situation and
Bancroft and Agnes of God and Seeley who
survived her childhood and a bad
marriage and finally finds freedom and
herself Whoopi Goldberg in the color
purple
as the strong-willed legendary country
singer Patsy Cline Jessica Lange and
sweet dreams
as an elderly woman determined to get
back to her childhood home Geraldine
page in the crypt about
as a passionate woman who Braves the new
world to create a new life for herself
Meryl Streep in Out of Africa
I consider this woman the greatest
actress in the English language the
winners Geraldine page
thank you all I wanted to say while
Marie is here thank you for the mirror
repertory company so much remotes
memories they'll thank a horton Foote
for all this I'm so glad I'm so glad the
three members of the Academy responded
to carry watts away I did evidently
that's because the way he wrote it and I
want to thank you for this for all of us
in the company John heard and Carlin and
Richard Bradford and Rebecca and was
also the beautiful eye of Fred Murphy
and the masterful direction and his film
debut as a director Peter Masterson
but mainly it's horton fall with all
this
you